ever since those scenes of biden alone
at the conference table at camp david
last week
something felt weird about this entire
situation
what was going on that none of biden's
top cabinet officials were with him at
that pivotal time was it just extended
alone time biden needed with jill it's
very odd
and when word leaked last night that joe
biden's cia director william burns had
met with a top taliban leader on monday
but we weren't surprised relying on the
good graces of the taliban either
they've cut some deal with the taliban
we don't know about and lord knows what
we paid for that or we're making a
really another disastrous calculation
here
now this raises lots of questions first
why send the cia director and not a
state department official and what were
the parameters of the talks did the cia
director push to get the august 31st
deadline extended
did he ask if any americans were being
held against their will or did he demand
their immediate release and safe passage
well if so presumably he said something
like that what did we give up for that
guarantee
it's hard to believe that the taliban
just did this or promised anything out
of the goodness of their hearts come on
this entire scenario has been so fraught
with lies and mishandling
misrepresentations we frankly don't know
what to think
but one thing we do know is that after
making a cold political calculation
president biden announced today that he
was in fact
bowing to the taliban's wishes and
sticking to the august 31st troop
withdrawal date
the sooner we can finish the better
each day of operations brings added risk
to our troops
but
the completion by august 31st depends
upon the taliban continuing to cooperate
and allow access to the airport for
those who were trans were transporting
out and no disruptions to our operations
it's always good to hear the president
of the united states so it's depending
on the taliban to cooperate
okay
now while the majority of americans
believe we needed to be out of
afghanistan years ago they certainly
cannot like the appearance the
appearance at least that it is the
taliban not our president calling the
shots
it's even making biden's biggest fans
nervous
it's a not the greatest look we've got
the taliban says nope and president
biden has to say no you could also look
at this as a tremendously humiliating
moment of american humiliation
leaving forced to leave on the taliban's
clock i think history will judge this
moment as a very dark period for the
united states
and as if the humiliation could not get
worse the taliban is doing the media
circuit sounding triumphant and unmoving
today they announced that afghans oh
they'll be staying put doesn't want they
don't want them leaving the country but
that americans should just concentrate
on removing your citizens only
we want them to evacuate all four
nationals by august 31st and we are not
in favor of allowing afghans to leave
heartbreaking but again to be expected
the biden administration not only comes
across as weak but as feckless and inept
which is what happens when you elect a
man who should be playing bingo with his
nurse before hitting the buffet for the
4 30 pm senior special
and while we're talking about details
and terms that are being hidden from the
american people
the true scope of the refugee situation
must be revealed
importing tens of thousands or hundreds
of thousands of afghans the united
states is bound to pose major challenges
with huge financial cultural and
security costs
of course but i didn't want you to
believe that he's got this thing this
whole vetting thing totally under
control
we're conducting
thorough
security screening and the intermediate
stops they're making for anyone who is
not a us citizen
or a lawful permanent resident of the
united states
anyone arriving in the united states
will have undergone a background check
oh a background check with those great
afghan files now raise your hand if you
trust the people behind the current
border crisis here and the afghanistan
debacle to properly vet each and every
one of these people
the fact is we've already seen potential
bad actors nearly slip through the
system defense one is reporting earlier
today that security screeners at the elk
wade air base in qatar have detected
that at least one of the afghans who was
evacuated from kabul has potential ties
to isis oh goody
you might say hold on ingram it's just
one person caught before arriving in the
united states
but here's the thing
it's not just one person
defense one goes on to report the dod
has flagged up to 100 of the 7 000
afghans evacuated as prospective
recipients of the special immigration
visas as potential matches
to intel agency watchlists
well it's just a hundred
now remember we will likely be bringing
in thousands if not hundreds of
thousands more refugees from afghanistan
enough is enough
so right now right away the gop has to
step up we need real oversight here not
symbolism
our country's in danger the gop must
press for immediate answers to the
following questions
number one
why are non-americans being evacuated
before americans
number two how many americans are likely
to be left behind what will happen to
them
number three how many non-americans are
being brought to this country now the
real number is there any reason to
believe that the vetting is
actually being done in accordance with
u.s law is there any reason to believe
that the veterans have any interest
other than open borders
and number four
where are the non-americans going to be
settled
and do do do state and local officials
have any say in that matter
number five are we paying the taliban to
stop them from attacking the airport if
so under what legal authority are these
payments being made
all of this
has to be investigated immediately
biden says now's not the time yes now is
the time
the gop must also be prepared to go to
court
every american's got to get out of there
but our constitution and our laws have
to be followed every step of the way
the biden people as i just said just
lost that case
on the mexico state and mexico policy at
the supreme court we have to assume
they're breaking the law here as well
and finally the gop must make clear that
it will not support more defense
spending until austin millie and
sullivan are all gone otherwise we're
just going to be throwing good money
after bad they'll start listening then
biden's team is not going to act in good
faith there's no point in pretending
otherwise
the democrats cannot be allowed to take
a crisis of their own making
and then turn around and use that crisis
to change or flout u.s refugee policy
they've already tried that on the border
because they turn the border into a
magnet and women and babies are showing
up there it's desperate we now have to
let everybody in
even if doing so is contrary to u.s law
no way it's time for gop members to do
their constitutional duty to protect
what's left of our laws and our national
security
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else